shazam's back you're back in the costume
talk about getting in shape what's it
like putting the costume on and doing
this again and doing it big huge yeah
well we we we had more time and more
budget you know the first one we were
kind of an untested ip uh not a lot of
people knew who shazam was more people
knew batman superman wonder woman all
that stuff so we were this kind of
the little engine that could and
everyone was wondering you know how will
the movie do and then we did you know
quite well so now there's more faith in
us as a franchise and warner brothers
has been so supportive in dc and so they
gave us some more money and some more
time and some newer cooler suits and uh
it was it was awesome
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
we all got to jump back into these
characters that we were already you know
kind of creating uh on the first one now
we get to revisit them and get deeper
with them and more nuanced with them and
keep building relationships between the
different characters i mean oh that's
the fun stuff yeah it seems really funny
like you guys have some chemistry that's
on fire
firecrackers thanks man i want to ask
you i'd be remiss if i didn't bring it
up you've been recently speaking about
mental health issues and i feel like
it's such an important topic just
at this time coming out of the pandemic
why is that so important to you i
appreciate it wholeheartedly i i really
appreciate that and yeah man i mean
basically uh back in 2017 right before i
booked this job i had a full-on mental
breakdown i didn't realize that my whole
life i had been struggling with clinical
depression at various times struggling
with anxiety probably my entire life
until i had this total breakdown and i
went to this life-changing life-saving
therapy
and uh and so once i figured out what i
was going through and how i got there
and why i ended up being who i was and
all the help that i needed to get
i was like well uh we need to be talking
about like i can't talk about anything
else that's really what it is i think
every there are so many problems in the
world but if you trace all those
problems back down to their root it's
somebody's broken heart or broken mind
every bad thing that goes on in this
world we can
ultimately i think we can correct out
those courses if we go and just heal
people heal their minds heal their
hearts and that starts with them
figuring out how to truly love
themselves and then us them figuring out
how to love other people and that's i i
can't stop talking about that
i want my check back from my therapist
i'm hiring a new one um before you run
away there's no good photo shoot without
a boombox you brought the sounds you
guys turned it into a whole
you always got to bring the vibes man i
think i genuinely think music makes life
better so
once once god gave us bluetooth speakers
i bring them everywhere i bring them on
set i have these really cool ones
there's something called sound box they
have these like crate speakers they're
like party in a box i'll bring them to
set i play on stage all day long i'll
just like play tunes because it makes
everybody a little happier you know it
just does it's a it's a beautiful you
know
balm for the soul and and if you play
music that has the right vibe to it all
of a sudden everyone is a little bit
happier and can work a little harder and
you're in it together and it's like yeah
life isn't so bad
well said you're inspirational and i
thank you i thank you for all your good
work you're putting in and i thank you
for doing superhero movies because
they're damn funny bro thank you thank
you go see it shazam fury the guides
only in theaters right around christmas
you hear a speaker in the background
because zachary's hiding in the back
[Music]